vi dicessi che usualmente i bambini
venivano vestiti di rosa e invece le
bambine venivano vestite di blu
forse non ci credereste perché oggi la
consuetudine diversa però nel xviii
secolo avveniva esattamente questo
addirittura gli uomini erano soliti
vestirsi di rosa con abiti di seta e
incredibili ricami floreali questo oggi
ci risulterebbe particolarmente strano e
non consueto cosa differenziava gli
abiti nei bambini
in realtà non il colore si tendeva a
vestire i bambini sempre in bianco
perché ovviamente per una questione
pratica non ce ne era necessario vestire
i bambini di un colore diverso si
sceglieva il bianco perché era facile da
lavare
facile da candeggiare ed estremamente
pratico non c'è la distinzione di genere
tra bambino e bambina entrambi vestivano
con abiti lunghi bianchi che si
differenziavano per piccoli particolari
vi dirò di più in rosa era scelto per i
maschietti perché era prossimo al rosso
il rosso che è percepito come un colore
aggressivo passionale e quindi si
sceglieva alle rosa che comunque diciamo
era più socialmente accettabile meno
aggressivo mentre il blu beh richiamava
il cielo il velo della vergine maria e
quindi era chiaramente più consono per
le bambine e quindi mi direte voi perché
oggi è diverso quando ho iniziato a
cambiare nel 1930 circa perché perché
gli uomini hanno iniziato ad andare al
lavoro vestendosi con abiti un po
formali e con colori tendenzialmente
neutri o comunque scuri che rendevano il
loro abbigliamento ma per l'appunto più
professionale e più serio e le donne che
invece erano coloro che gestivano il
focolare domestico gli angeli del
focolare tendevano a vestirsi invece con
tinte pastello di rosa o di altri colori
ma in realtà
non c'è stata una grande distinzione
soprattutto nell'ambito degli abiti dei
bambini fino agli anni 50 quando in
realtà è avvenuto qualcosa
la barbie ha consolidato lo stereotipo
per cui le bambine si vestivano di rosa
ovviamente non era ancora così
codificato come lo immaginiamo oggi
perché oggi quando immaginiamo e rosa
tendiamo a identificarlo come il colore
delle donne e l'azzurro o il blu è il
colore degli uomini o comunque così nel
nostro immaginario
poi è successo qualcosa infatti è
arrivato il movimento femminista che in
qualche modo ha tentato di rompere lo
stereotipo del appunto del colore rosa
cercando di utilizzare uno stile più
neutro che in qualche modo fosse non
legate e colori sono arrivati gli anni
ottanta cosa ma cosa è successo né anni
80 hanno consolidato quello che lo
stereotipo attuale quindi bambini
vestiti di blu bambine vestite di rosa
non solo bambini che fanno i giochi da
bambini quindi giocano con le
costruzioni e le macchinine e le bambine
giocano con le bambole non solo
cosa è successo negli anni 80 e gli anni
80 è esplosa quella che la cosiddetta
diagnosi prenatale quindi di fatto tutti
eravamo in grado di sapere volendo il
sesso del futuro nascituro quindi
sapevamo già se avremmo avuto una bimba
ho un bimbo e quindi avremo appeso il
nostro fiocco rosa o il nostro fiocco
azzurro e quindi li il marketing è
dilagato e quindi abbiamo la nostra
consuetudine ma vedendo un po ai giorni
nostri più recente
c'è un'altra cosa che in italia e rosa
incredibilmente rosa le quote rosa
le poter osa lo saprete sicuramente sono
un provvedimento in genere temporaneo
che viene adottato per equilibrare la
presenza femminile all'interno di organi
decisionali che siano organi di tipo
istituzionale che siano cda quindi
consigli di amministrazione di aziende
in realtà il provvedimento ha uno scopo
nobile che è quello di ridurre la
discriminazione
che c'è tra uomini e donne nei posti di
comando
queste quote però hanno un problema sono
rosa nel resto d europa e comunque nel
resto del mondo
le quote non si chiamano rosa sono le
cosiddette quote di genere quindi nelle
istituzioni europee
così vengono chiamate solo in italia
sono rosa e se ci pensate
abbiamo un sacco di cose rosa i
parcheggi rosa
i treni rosa i romanzi rosa le medicine
rosa i treni perché perché color rosa
oggi si tende a identificare il
femminile e o quasi un sinonimo rosa è
sinonimo di donna perché perché il rosa
si associa a qualcosa che richiama la
femminilità l'emotività un certo tipo di
visione delle cose più morbido pensate
ai romanzi rosa di fatto i romanzi rosa
non hanno tutta questa avventura queste
chissà quali trame avvincenti ma ruotano
intorno a una storia sentimentale
quindi il rosa come identificativo di un
qualcosa estremamente femminile
e allora io mi faccio vi pongo un
quesito qual è il colore della
competenza e ve lo chiedo perchè perchè
sono un'imprenditrice e di fatto ho
fondato un'azienda e quindi per me
estremamente importante che chi lavora
con me o per me abbia delle competenze
qual è diciamo la assoluto al quale sono
arrivata io dopo anni e anni di lavoro
che il successo per scende dal genere
delle persone quando io ho fondato la
mia agenzia
ho pensato a due cose fondamentali
la prima era che volevo lavorare in
smart working perché volevo lasciare le
persone libere di poter scegliere dove
vivere e perché di fatto trovavo
veramente poco poco utile obbligare
qualcuno a lavorare in un posto fisico
scelto da me
che avrebbe potuto non essere il posto
ideale per la persona con la quale
avrebbe con la quale avrei lavorato e
quindi cosa ho pensato non solo
lascio la libertà che per me è la cosa
più importante sia da un punto di vista
professionale che personale per un
essere umano ma ho anche pensato posso
attingere ai migliori professionisti e
alle migliori professionisti nel mio
campo ora di cosa mi occupo io
io ho un agenzia digitale che si occupa
di una cosa estremamente peculiare non
ci occupiamo di social che se volete
sono una sfera del digitale che in
genere viene associato alle donne ma ci
occupiamo di una cosa più tecnica che
l'asse ok linz e l'insieme delle
tecniche diciamo delle attività che
servono per posizionare un sito web su
google
di fatto si tratta di un'attività
tecnica che ha a che fare con i
linguaggi di programmazione che ha a che
fare con delle competenze estremamente
specifiche verticali come si usa dire
oggi ma non solo per poter lavorare con
me
oltre chiaramente a avere competenze
estremamente verticali e tecnologiche e
necessario avere dei requisiti
fondamentali perché siamo a distanza la
comunicazione immediata come stasera tra
me e voi c'è uno schermo lo schermo di
un tablet lo schermo di un pc o di un
cellulare quindi è fondamentale che chi
lavora con me o per me abbia delle
capacità comunicative che sia in grado
di passare oltre questo schermo e dare
una serie di informazioni
ora per me la competenza è fondamentale
e quindi come vi ho detto anche saper
comunicare è una competenza conosce i
linguaggi di programmazione la
competenza che io non so che colore li
vogliamo dare
ovviamente me lo chiedo spesso però vi
faccio vedere come il composto il mio
staff
questo il mio staff e siamo tutte donne
siamo tutte donne e abbiamo condividiamo
un sistema di valori
condividiamo la nostra quotidianità
lavorativa e di fatto abbiamo due
caratteristiche che ci legano tutte
insieme
prima è quella delle competenze ovvero
tutte le ragazze che lavorano commentate
le donne che lavorano con me hanno
capacità tecnologiche verticali la mia
socia fa la sviluppatrice che in qualche
modo nell'immaginario collettivo se
vogliamo tornare i nostri colori è una
competenza che coloreremo di azzurro non
di rosa il resto delle mie ragazze come
me si occupa di posizionamento sui
motori di ricerca un tipo di attività
che ha a che fare si con il linguaggio e
quindi con la comprensione di cosa
cercano le persone ma anche molto con la
tecnologia e quindi forse sì il
linguaggio fossero coloriamo di rosa la
tecnologia i linguaggi programmazione
abbiamo maturi come avremmo di azzurro e
invece no però non condividiamo sono le
competenze condividiamo anche la vision
del lavoro e condividiamo una
propensione verso l'inclusività la
condivisione della della personalità di
ognuno e soprattutto tutte siamo molto
attenti al concetto di inclusività
all'interno del posto di lavoro
motivo per il quale abbiamo deciso di
istituire la quota azzurra in modo tale
da non discriminare nessuno
ora vorrei lasciarvi con una riflessione
e quelli che sono i tre ingredienti a
mio avviso fondamentali per essere un
leader di successo un manager di
successo un imprenditore di successo e
soprattutto creare un team di persone
felici che lavorano bene perché un team
di persone felici lavora bene produce e
rende felici i vostri clienti come si fa
tre sono gli ingredienti fiducia
consapevolezza e in assoluto inclusività
queste tre questi tre ingredienti non
hanno nessun colore o se invece
preferite
hanno tutti i colori dell'arcobaleno
grazie
[Applauso]